The world has a way of changing.
And we've changed too.
There are moments that separate us.
But we always come back together.
We heard y'all need a little love out here.
Y'all ever thought about the wild missions we've been on?
We've taken out planes, trains, tanks.
I'm not going to think about the submarine.
And now we got cars flying in the air?
Who is he?
Jacob is Dom's brother.
It's been a long time, Dom.
Little brother.
You always say "Never turn your back on family."
But you turned your back on me.
Now, your little family is in my world.
Whatever is on you, is on us.
He's got his own private army.
We need help.
No way.
So, how do you all want to play this?
Fast.